my name is grow
it's time to meet the minion crew which
legend of show business voiced a
despicable mother how about the actor
who voiced the most roles in the film
let's check out who the talents are
behind those animated faces i've been
lucky to get roles like that and i'm
happy to do roles like crew number one
say hello to the real life group
watch out the world
here comes grow
steve carell has been bringing grew to
life for years
i have been recruited by a top secret
agency but in minions the rise of gru he
brings a young group to life oh my
favorite tiny relatives this was all
before he became the super villain he
was born to be
anyway thanks for all the hard work
today everyone
and spoiler alert it's stellar
oh good great
here we go little guru does have a bit
of a different sound from grown-up grew
we definitely wouldn't hate seeing more
young grew in the future how cute is he
yes i am pretty despicable you don't
want to cross me
number two he plays the most characters
for real though he voiced hundreds of
different characters but they all had
one thing in common that they were
perfectly yellow say hello to the man
behind the voices of every single minion
in the despicable me franchise
[Music]
the french animator behind the minions
also happens to casually be the director
producer and writer on all these films
which makes sense when it comes to how
his process in the booth can vary most
of the times i do the voices like before
having storyboards and on other
occasions i ask storyboards to help me
out number three she's everything
everywhere all at once
you know what i say to my mind
[Music]
and when she's getting into the minion
vibes she knows there's only one way to
dress
i'm in yellow so i must be so excited
right she was excited because of course
it's the minions but also because she
got to dive into something very new for
herself i found master chao to be
fascinating i mean she's an auntie i've
not played before michelle yeoh has had
an impressive career that included
everything from doing chongqi to star
trek to avatar and clearly she was busy
doing voice work for a while since she
also brought to life yuki in paws of
fury it is a real passion it doesn't
feel like work number four
is he the coolest villain of all well in
minions the rise of gru wild knuckles
certainly makes an impact it's ran
sometime
[Music]
alan arkin has been in multiple
award-winning movies throughout his
career but he hasn't done a whole lot of
voice-over for animation projects he
dove in for the series bojack horseman
in the mid-2010s people ask celebrities
trivia questions and before that his
only other voice gig was over 30 years
earlier in the 1982 film the last
unicorn
he may not do it often but we can assure
you he nails it as gru's favorite
villain everyone wants to know if you
had a lot of fun on the set number five
can you say fabulous villain
you seriously think a puny little child
can be a villain that is certainly the
case when it comes to bell bottom in
minions the rise of gru i look pretty
hot in an afro and and um
bell bottoms henson is a pro when it
comes to voice over lending her talents
to projects from ice age only one hunter
here my mate through the coop that's
great what to ralph breaks the internet
this man is on fire literal and
figurative fire to the simpsons when the
offer to play bell bottom came well she
couldn't say no it's the only time in
our business where you get to live the
story from beginning middle to end we
wouldn't hate a spin-off featuring this
queen villain should be someone you love
to hate you want them to get away and i
think i can do that number six the dame
of voice over
julie andrews also known as mary poppins
has lent her voice to countless projects
over the years and watching her work in
the booth well it's pretty magical
witnessing such a pro i just wanted to
congratulate you on stealing the pyramid
her confidence in the booth is no
surprise since she spent plenty of time
doing so as the one and only lady
whistle down in bridgerton she narrated
the film enchanted and brought voice to
a queen and shrek okay we think we can
definitely call her the dame of
voiceover nighty night my little
cabbages
let grandma give you a moochie
number seven
the doctor is in over the years we've
grown to love the incomparable russell
brand as dr nefario in the despicable me
franchise some fella just stole a
pyramid they're saying he makes all
other villains look lame
voiced a character version of himself
for the simpsons and the globe goes to
angry dad played eb in the movie hop and
maybe you recognized him as creak and
trolls he can really do it all you will
always be
one of the greats he brought the perfect
amount of dog expertise to nefario
bro
can you hear me number eight he didn't
have to claw his way into this one
we're pretty sure that jean-claude van
damme also known as jean-claude is the
only person who could have played this
villain we are coming for you man
sure most folks know him as an action
star fans of kung fu panda may also
recognize him as the voice of master
croc we're kind of shocked that he
hasn't done more voice over work number
nine we've got another action hero in
the house not just for kids but for
grownups too the legend that is dolph
lundgren joined the cast playing the
savvy's vengeance he's better known for
his on-screen roles but he's got all the
chops needed to voice an animated
character it's innocent it's fun it's
entertaining and they're very clever
these movies there number 10 a real
living legend
he may have played a villain but he's a
hero when it comes to the performance
industry they can expect to see one bad
dude named stronghold trejo's on-screen
career started way back in 1983 and it
never slowed down danny trejo may be an
old pro but that didn't mean he wasn't
inspired by his role i love dolph he's
just such a cool guy this guy is living
the dream the movie was a blast number
11 get ready for rams bottom returning
to the world of the minions was none
other than the voice we've come to know
as silas ramsbottom aka steve coogan
i am the league's director
silas ramsbottom
though others may know him as ozone and
reginald in the secret life of pets or
raisin in marmaduke great it's gonna be
a really good party number 12. the
multi-talented artist is here most of us
know him as the leader of the wu-tang
clan but this talented man has no limits
he is regularly working as an actor
composer producer and has even tried his
hand at writing and directing his cameo
as the biker man and minions the rise of
gru was short but oh so impactful it's
your lucky day chet i'm headed up the
coast number 13. xena is in the house
okay so being a warrior princess was
what made her famous but what made us
fall in love with her even more recently
was her turn as nunchuck chucking
weapons like her life depended on it
lawless has had cameos in countless
shows and movies even playing herself in
an episode of the simpsons once well
i mean
maybe we are meant for each other
number 14. when he's not on screen you
can probably find him in the voiceover
booth will arnett found himself plenty
busy recording countless projects from
chippendale rescue rangers to bojack
horseman to ratatouille to the lego
movies let's just agree to say that i'm
right playing mr perkins has been a long
gig but thank goodness it's been a great
one too there are a lot of new villains
out there younger than you
hungrier than you
younger than you number 15. we'd know
this voice anywhere this isn't michael
beatty's first time around voicing the
vnc announcer for the minions franchise
so much fun
it's a crime
would you believe he was part of the
care bears cast way back when in the 80s
did you recognize any of the actors
behind these voices which performer do
you think best suited their character
let us know in the comments and if you
digged it hit that thumbs up